esperábamos era en realidad lo que
teníamos planificado para este día pero
la lectura de este informe que debe
durar 8 horas empezó apenas hace tres
horas así que todavía nos quedan cinco
horas de audiencia y un informe muy
emotivo santiago primero hay que decir
que comienza con un relato de quiénes
eran esos diez atacantes del 13 de
noviembre dada no cierto mucha
información personal se centró
concretamente en el recorrido que hizo
salas de slam el último el único
sobreviviente de los comandos del 13 de
noviembre como paso del norte de parís
en el barrio 18 hasta el sur de parís
donde se escondió hasta que se dirigió
hacia bélgica también detalles sobre la
logística como alquilaron sus escondites
donde también ellos elaboraron los
explosivos como tenían 14 líneas
telefónicas para comunicarse cómo se
radicalizaron muchos de ellos fueron a
siria a entrenarse para disparar esas
calas micos con las que dieron muerte a
130 personas como tú bien decías un
informe muy detallado quizás no hay
información nueva pero en realidad es
muy emocionante volver a escuchar el
relato de esos hechos santiago erika
contanos cómo está atrás corriendo este
juicio decía que el informe fue muy
emotivo se están viviendo momentos muy
emotivos verdad porque se trata de una
herida abierta todavía para los
franceses
totalmente abierta y tú lo sabes que
dentro de las partes civiles hay
víctimas directas rescatados de los
ataques y también familiares de personas
que fallecieron así que fue muy difícil
sobre todo cuando el relato los hechos
de esa noche del 13 de noviembre sobre
todo cuando hablo de ese ataque a la
sala de conciertos bataclán donde
murieron 90 personas explicó que los
atacantes entraron durante tres minutos
de esperaron de forma indiscriminada y
luego 20 minutos disparando de manera
focalizada a la gente se escondía decía
él entre los muertos hubo momentos muy
emocionantes no sólo para esas víctimas
también para la prensa y los parisinos
en general e incluso vimos que mucha
gente salió con los ojos llorosos de
estas diferentes salas recordemos que
son más de 12 salas las que transmiten
lo que es este juicio yo puedo conversar
de hecho con una chilena madre de un
joven que falleció en la sala de
conciertos bataclán y con su hermana
ellos simplemente escucharon el relato
el comienzo del relato de lo que pasaba
en la sala de conciertos bataclán y
salieron porque no se sentían capaces de
escuchar todo lo que fue esa noche y
entender como estos jóvenes se
radicalizaron por cierto los están en
ese box muchos de ellos estaban con la
vista hacia abajo como si uno pensará
casi casi que sentían vergüenza de lo
que hicieron esa noche erika olavaría
muchísimas gracias por otro completísimo
reporte desde la capital francesa